all right
well thank you very much and welcome
everybody to my talk about how to not
pull your hair out while providing data
to the business we're going to talk
about uh unit testing data pipelines and
seeing the the crowds I think at least
everybody has pulled once out their hair
while doing so so nice to have you all
here
um yeah indeed I'm one of the
co-founders and data engineers at blend
data we build data pipelines for our
customers and today I'm going to tell a
little bit about what we have learned
during all those Journeys
so what to expect today first I'm going
to talk a little bit about automated
software testing
um what it is and why you would want to
use it
next some theoretical backgrounds about
testing so what it conceptually is next
we're having a practical example using
beer I thought that would be a nice use
case for the audience
and finally I have a recap where I have
some practical examples on how you can
use it for your products that you do on
a day-to-day basis
uh first of all I'm a little bit
interested how the audience is put
together so I'm interested in who is a
data scientist over here
who is a data analyst
okay data engineer
also plenty of you and software
engineers
also a few nice okay I think for
everybody in there I have some examples
that you can use because it will mainly
focus on python but you will see that in
a few slides
all right so first of all uh why
automated testing automated testing is a
principle that comes from software
engineering and it helps you in
delivering uh products that uh yeah
actually do what you expect them to do
so here I have a very trivial example a
python function that just adds one to a
number and then yeah returns it back
well you can write some tests for that
it helps you making a more robust code
but it also helps future you so you can
see the test and uh
see what it is expected to do
so here I have created a very simple
test uh one test case enters four into
the function and then five comes out and
one test case enters five and then six
comes out well this is very trivial you
probably wouldn't use that in your
projects but it shows the ID
uh then you also have a testing
framework and what a testing framework
is is some piece of code that runs the
tests on the right side and checks
whether all your so-called best cases
succeed or fail when they succeed they
are green
and otherwise they they are red which
you will see later on
Okay so
after this practical example more about
how tests will work in general and I
think that's nice to know in order to
apply it to your data Pipelines
so uh to make it more yeah more
mathematical we can describe a test as y
equals FX and F is in this case your
python function
X are your inputs and Y is the output of
your python function when you have put X
into it and when you have a test you
check that the the actual output so your
y equals some certain y that you expect
up front
so how can we apply this theoretical
model to an actual data pipeline
we have the same equation however for
our inputs we use a data frame and that
could be any type of the data frames
that yeah you might have seen in the
talks this morning but you could use
pandas or Pi spark for example to use
that and as the outputs you also have a
data frame which uh probably would be
the same type as you have put into it
so how can we apply this model to beer
um to make it more concrete we are
tasked with a specific task and we need
to provide the business with insights
about the most popular beers that we
have within Eindhoven so we can create
as a company profitable and very tasty
new ones
so in this example I'm going to retrieve
some data from depth I think many of you
are familiar with that app
I have made a Biden script that uh
retrieves the data from the depth page
processes with the logic that our
business wants so grouping the pairs by
a specific category and then aggregate
some ratings about the Bears and then
it's written to a CSV file that contains
all the insights that we want to know
so how does the code look like here I
have an example I can imagine it's not
very readable for everybody so we can
zoom in a little bit
and it's not our final code but
something we are stacked with and for
it's not a very uh it's not necessary
that you know all the details but I will
walk you through uh I over
so first what we do is uh we Loop over
all breweries we have in Eindhoven
um then in the second part we parse some
information about the Bears and a little
bit uh below halfway we do some
processing on the data to make it
possible to do some aggregations on it
and then finally we group the Bears by
their specific style and write it down
to a CSV file
but how is this testable because it is a
long script also not very readable and
also still hard to test
so in order to do that we're going to
walk to a five-step process together and
in the end we have a working test that
validates our code but for first what we
are going to do is Define our FX so what
is uh the function and what should be
the corresponding inputs and outputs
then we're going to refactor our code so
split it up into multiple parts that are
both testable and more readable
as a third step we're going to generate
some synthetic data
then we're going to create the actual
test in by test and finally I'm I'm
having a bonus tip for you where you can
even automate the checking process even
further
okay so here we have uh our script but
does anyone do uh do a guess about what
our FX function would be in this case
there's currently one function before
refactoring but we're looking for the FX
part wherein data frame is inputted and
a data frame is outputted
yeah indeed the command gives it away a
little bit the part that is over there
that is the actual FX in our python
script so let's refactor it into
something more readable and then we end
up with this code right now
on the top we have the extract part that
is the part that retrieves the data from
adapt and puts it into a data frame the
second part really contains all the
pandas logic in order to create
something readable from it and the final
part is writing to a file
so then the next step is generating some
synthetic data well why do we need to
generate some synthetic data and not
just use the in-depth webpage because
it's already there and the code is
already working right
well a unit test prescribes you that you
should have no external dependencies and
what are external dependencies external
dependencies are yeah uh systems or uh
yeah external parts that your code
interfaces to in order to make it work
and going to the in-depth webpage
is an external dependency because we
have our python code living over there
we need to make a request to the
untapped web page and then maybe the
in-depth webpage is down and it returns
an error
and then our python test will fail but
this gives a wrong Insight because right
now we could have the idea that our own
python code is not functioning well the
actual problem is with the network so we
want to remove out those dependencies so
we only validate that our internal code
is actually working and in order to do
that we need to create some synthetic
data
so if we go back to our initial function
we have to think about what does the
input data frame look like and what is
the structure of that
and what does our actual output data
frame look like and what is the
structure for that data frame
all right so I've already ran the code
for you and we're going to look uh how
does the how these data frames should
look like
in this case I've picked the robawa
brewery we have three types of beer that
we are going to process and as you see
we have six columns with the the name
the style the alcohol percentage the
ratings and the number of ratings it has
well some parts uh they all contain
strings some parts contain percentages
it's important to know this about your
data structure that you will use as an
input because your synthetic data that
you will use also needs to have the same
characteristics
okay so now we know this for our input
data frame we can have a look at how our
output data frame should look like
while our output data frame just has
four columns only with the Styles
without the the ship types in them they
all contain numbers and they are all
floats in this case or decimal numbers
so okay now we know this characteristics
how can we then uh create them for our
tests
well there are many ways to do that but
the easiest is uh to implement that in
pure python uh directly because your
tests will also be in Python code
here I created a data frame from an
python list and here we see that is not
the actual data but something within
that we have come up with in this case
we use the two bears that are brewed by
blend data we're not an actual Brewery
but in this case we can use that for uh
for our tests we have an IPA and uh yeah
a stronger and a lighter beer and we
have our expected data frame that just
contains one row and the average results
that are a decimal number in this case
okay
the next step is installing by test and
why are we going to use by test well in
the beginning of the talk I mentioned
that we need a test Runner and by test
is one of the test Runners that is
compatible with python and is Apparently
one of the most used so we're going to
stick with that one
then we need to change our folder
structure a little bit where our python
code is in in order to make buy test
work and this is what we finally end up
with
the bottom file is uh the file we just
refactored and on the top we have a
folder with tests that contains an empty
init file and a test1 file
okay so now we can create a test and
that will look something like this and
I'm going to walk you through what
happens in this file
number one we input the transform
function that we had we factored out so
that contains all the logic for
processing the pandas data frame
then in step two we create a function in
our python file that starts with test
that means that it is a test and I will
also be picked up by by test
then at three we create the synthetic
input data frame that I've shown you on
the previous slides
on step four we do an actual call to the
function that contains our business
logic
and in step five uh we create our
synthetic output data frame
and then in Step six we execute the
actual tests in this case I'm making use
of the pandas testing module that's an
helper module that helps you to compare
your input data frame and output data
frame and shows you the results in order
to give you some information that could
help you for debugging
when they are equal
it does nothing and when they aren't
equal it will raise an error and your
test will fail
okay so now I've created the test and I
can run it with a simple command by test
and then it will show you that our test
is green and everything is nice
yay
hopefully at least because as you
remember the business wouldn't be the
business if they came with a new
question about our data well nice nice
Lars but we have four tasting locations
in eindhover and not just one and then
I'm like yeah I know give me a minute
and I will fix it for you
so what I try to do I try to create some
code so it's modular and easily
extendable so I will add the other
breweries we have in eindhofer and
everything will be fine
is it
well not exactly because here we have a
new type of beer that isn't processed
correctly in our data pipeline it's a
specifically a non-alcoholic beer and it
ends up in our final data frame as such
well I don't know about you but for me
it's not really clear what this type of
beer is so we have to change our initial
implementation in Python
well in order to do that we first create
a new test case because our initial test
case apparently didn't cover this type
of data so we need to create a new test
case that facilitates checking whether
this works or not
and uh it looks uh very similar to the
previous test however the only
difference is on the top where I Define
our synthetic input data it now contains
also the string non-alcoholic IPA that
apparently isn't working properly in our
current code implementation
but what I expected to be is that there
you see it on the bottom part it should
contain non-alcoholic and then the
values we expect
so now I have created tests I can change
the implementation in Python
and if I look in the codes I just found
I found that those two lines of code are
actually where the problem arises so
after some fiddling and after some
trying I end up with this alternative
instead of using split I'm going to use
R split which yeah separates the style
on a different location in the text
so now I can run by test again in order
to validate that it has worked and oh
it didn't
so right now before I already deployed
this uh code and delivered the result to
the business I have catched errors up
front so
it gives me a an error message about
what has ran wrong
so in short it says you have two records
in your output data frame instead of one
well what might have gone wrong
this is the test case that has gone
wrong and maybe a few of you already
spotted that I made a mistake in our
change of the codes because currently it
doesn't process these two records
correctly it doesn't strip out all the
spaces and that's why we end with two
lines
so what I can do I've added the bottom
line and then I can run by test again
and as you will see everything is fine
now so right now I didn't have to pull
out my hair where the business was
coming back hey the the regular beers
aren't working anymore because I've
catched this problem by running tests
before deploying my solution
to to the business so to say
so right now we are ready to release
but I still have a bonus tip for you
because right now it really depends on
your team and how eager they are to run
by test before deploying this uh to the
to the repository or before delivering
the value to the business so how can we
automate that part as well
you can run that in CI and I'm not sure
who of you is familiar with what CI is
can I see Hands who does know what it is
all right cool plenty of you but for
those who don't know I will explain
uh CI is a kind of automation process
that you can run on top of your git
repository in order to do some checks on
your code base and you can often
customize that yourself about what that
does
for GitHub you can use GitHub actions
and for gitlab you can use gitlab CI and
for Azure devops you have Azure
pipelines which you can use
but the process looks as follows when
you use CI often your implementation of
code that is working is on the main
branch and when you want to add a
feature you often create a separate
Branch for that
and in this case all the dots are the
commits on the specific branches and
here you see that on the first commit CI
has ran and in this case the CI filled
so when you have white Nest which you
can run in your CI then your CI checks
out your codes
runs the buy test checks on your
repository and then reports the result
back
so in this case you can you often do
that while running on a pull request so
if you right now create a full request
from your future Branch to your master
Branch you will see that on the first
commit the CI has failed on the second
it has failed and finally after some
changes to make it working it was Green
and you can also automate
this process in order to prevent that
wrong code is merged into your main
branch because you can disable merging
of your pull request if the tests are
not succeeding
to make it concrete this is an example
of GitHub actions where you can run a
test on your pull request in this case
the merge pull request isn't disabled
but you can make this button grayed out
if your tests are failing
all right a short recap how you can make
your data pipelines more robust using
tests
first think of what is your actual FX so
what is your python logic that contains
the business logic
then refactor your code so that uh this
part of your python code is also an
actual function
then you need to generate some synthetic
data to make it testable
then you create a then you create a test
and finally I would recommend that you
create a process in your CI in order to
automate this part
all right
um these are the basics for those of you
who are might be uh maybe already
familiar with that there are also some
steps that you can take it to even a
higher level
uh today we only talked about unit tests
and unit tests are the so-called bottom
of the testing pyramid for those of you
who aren't familiar with that this is a
testing pyramid and the width of the
pyramid stands for how plenty uh how
many tests you have and the health
stands for how complex they are so you
unit tests you often have a lot of them
which are not so complex they are also
often easy to run but
you often run your python script
somewhere maybe in airflow or maybe in a
serverless kind of environment and then
you can create more complex tests that
also take into account the runtime of
airflow or your serverless environment
or maybe you can also take into account
the process of talking to an API or the
in-depth webpage
a book that has helped me at least to
yeah become more confident in that is
architecture patterns with python it's
not necessarily a data science or a data
engineering book it's more focused
towards software engineering
and today we also used pandas but if
you're using spark for example you can
use the data compile package in order to
do your asserts on five spark data
frames
well if you want to have a look at the
code examples used today you can look at
my GitHub
um
and that that's it thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
it's foreigners any questions from the
audience
thank you for your talk
okay yeah yeah
so what I end up doing as a data analyst
that I wrote 200 lines of code and then
in the end I oh [ __ ] let's do tests and
then I got stuck at do we have to write
like one single test I know like a unit
test you typically want to do one single
piece of code but with like with data
like every line is a single
transformation so I was wondering if you
have some good practices or rules of
thumb how you decide on like when do we
have to make like a new test or like
split the code and have like uh yeah
after this test I've test one two three
four five on your code without having
like for every single function a
separate test
yeah there's I think no exact science uh
about how to do that uh what at least me
helps very often is uh yeah this wasn't
maybe the most uh the most proper
example about how to write clean code
but uh for demo purposes I think it
would it is fine but
um in uh in other cases is often a good
idea to group some kind of functionality
that either does one thing together in a
function
uh and when you have 200 lines of code I
can guess that it's not one function so
I'd say you can probably break it into
um yeah 10 or maybe 20 functions that do
something and then it would be wise to
test each individual function
uh because also the more often the
longer is the actual code that you need
to put under test also the more complex
the the inputs and outputs that you need
to set up in order to make your test uh
testable so to say so breaking it up in
multiple functions also simplifies
writing tests for that so it's also a
little bit of experimentation but I
think writing smaller functions also
helps you in writing easier tests and
also spending less time writing them
okay thank you
any other questions
thank you
um previously oh yeah thank you thank
you for the talk of course and uh
previously when I used some uh testing
with pandas I stumbled into null values
that are like one
and like a numpy n a is not equal to
another numpy in a right which makes
pandas data frames that contain no
values not equal to each other even
though they are actual equal how do you
usually solve that problem
um yeah it actually depends because when
you create your data frame you can
either enter I think no values or none
values but also the the testing module
of pandas itself
um it gives you some options about how
specific it should be on whether those
two frames should be equal or not should
it be all values or should the should it
be the whole data frame or is it allowed
that indexes are different or is it also
possible to allow that
data types are different in the sense
that it it would be an in 8 or n16 for
example
um so yeah you can tune your input data
frame or you can tune the settings for
the the pandas testing module
thank you